what's up guys bang bang this weekend
Bitcoin was all about regulation Gary
ginsler and the SEC cracking down on
both coinbase and binance along with the
trend of all the other companies and
projects that they have continued to
increase their scrutiny on now this is
interesting in the light of Bitcoin
because Bitcoin seems to be the only
asset both in the United States and
internationally that has passed all the
filters Bitcoin is not deemed a security
by the SEC by the cftc or any other
regulator around the world for some
reason maybe because it's decentralized
maybe because it actually doesn't have a
creator that people know about and maybe
because there was no premon ultimately
Bitcoin has passed those filters and it
continues to kind of skate free on the
other side so whenever you see these
regulatory crackdowns you have to ask
yourself is this a net positive for
Bitcoin now I actually disagree with
those people who are cheering on bigger
government and more government action
but at the same time I understand that
yes this likely is a net positive for
Bitcoin when new investors come into the
Bitcoin and crypto industry if one of
the assets has clear regulatory
Frameworks and the rest of the assets
don't there is going to be some subset
of investors that say I'm going to put
my dollars in the one that has the clear
regulatory framework that's just how
markets especially with institutional
investors work now that's not the only
news of what happened this week we also
continue to get hash rate rising and
hitting a new all-time high there's been
an explosion of hash rate over the last
couple of years and even though China
ordered all those miners out of their
country a couple years ago we continue
to see people around the world buy
machines find energy at a low cost plug
in the machines and continue to secure
the Bitcoin Network Bitcoin is the
strongest most decentralized Computing
Network in the world there is no single
centralized coordinator of the entire
network so there's a bunch of volunteers
who are going after that economic reward
it's a true free market it's a beautiful
thing to see now last but not least
Kathy Wood of Arc invest she was
interviewed this past week and she
Remains The Bull of bulls she says that
Arc invest their base case is Bitcoin
hitting six hundred thousand dollars by
2030 and their bull case is it hitting a
million dollars in the same time frame
in our big Ideas 2023 it's on our
website uh you'll find our uh our our
digital asset forecast so
um we we expect the Bitcoin price our
base case is 600 000 Plus
our bull case is more than one million
dollars and I think as time goes on
what's the timeline for that Kathy 20 30
20 30. 20 30. 20 30. I mean if we went
back and looked you know two or three
years ago conversations you would have
talked about Bitcoin being much higher I
imagine than 26 000 right are you
disappointed in where things are and has
that changed something really important
happened very recently during the
Regional Bank crisis if you will notice
the Regional Bank stocks were imploding
and Bitcoin went from 19
000 up to roughly thirty thousand I got
to so what was that that was a flight to
safety a flight to safety think about
that now that's really interesting
because one of Kathy's big arguments is
that Bitcoin is actually a flight to
safety it's a flight to Safety in the
crypto market and it also happens to be
a flight to safety from the Legacy
banking system if Kathy Wood is right
there's a lot of upside to bitcoin now
of course whether it's regulation
whether it's underlying metrics like
cash rate or it's individual investors
like Kathy Wood talking about Bitcoin
regardless of all the noise and all the
developments Bitcoin continues to
produce block after block after block of
transactions doing exactly what it was
designed to do ultimately Bitcoin is
Bitcoin and Bitcoin seems to be the
safest bet in the crypto industry so far
I've long said that I think that Bitcoin
is the riskiest asset That Wall Street
investors have in their portfolio but is
the single most boring and safest asset
that many of the most hardcore crypto
investors have in their portfolio and
that's exactly where I personally want
to sit I want to be in the conservative
asset of the risky people and I want to
be in the risky asset of the
conservative people that's it for this
week I hope you guys enjoy these updates
I'll see you all next Saturday